Few people know about this ancient forest.
Maybe because the Cape is known more for its famed boats than its woodlands.
Or maybe as the cities and farms expand,...
...the woods came to be a resource rather than a refuge.
Fortunately, Platbos forest remains,...
...threatened now only by alien vegetation and our lack of knowledge.
When you walk through Platbos for the first time, you feel a sense of magic.
Lights streaming through the leaves of low canopy, rich forested fragrances...
...and the sense that time stands still.
A positive journey has begun in this forest.
Every year, a tribe assembles to open their hearts and to use their hands.
They come to give back to the forest its trees and to celebrate, in joy and song.
Enjoy a weekend of connecting with nature and each other.
Join the rhythm.
Come plant trees and dance under the ancient stinkwood tree.
Rediscover. Reconnect. Reforest.